Day Thanksgiving tradition that began
nearly a century ago right here in New
York the city's annual Thanksgiving Day
Parade with its balloons and other
attraction steps off in front of
millions of Spectators it's back to full
swing this year after two years of
coveted restrictions and the parade
follows a two and a half mile route down
34th Street and that is where we find
Elise Preston in the middle of all the
excitement along the parade route Elise
good morning and Happy Thanksgiving to
you and yours
good morning to you and Happy
Thanksgiving Vlad we're still about two
hours away from the start of the parade
but you can see the balloons are set and
families have been lined up all morning
this is a tradition that for many kicks
off the holiday season
all dressed and ready to take flight
Dino and baby dino are just some of the
familiar faces said to Glide over the
streets of New York City for the annual
New York's Thanksgiving Day Parade
everybody has grown up with the
Thanksgiving Parade right it's actually
part of Thanksgiving and New York City
is gosh it's exactly where you want to
be about three million people will be on
the sidelines watching 8 000 performers
officially usher in the holiday season
it's the first parade not under the
shadow of kovid since the pandemic began
we are here to see the balloons for the
very first time we are New Yorkers one
and raised but I was excited to bring my
daughter for the first time and it's a
beautiful day for many the fun started
yesterday as crowds gathered all day to
watch the balloons inflate we didn't
realize how big they are
now we see why they're all hide down
this year there will be 16 massive
character balloons 28 floats a dozen
marching bands 700 clowns and of course
Santa Claus my favorite thing was the
soccer one my favorite one was actually
that reward ticket the NYPD is boosting
security as a precaution for the holiday
parade after two recent mass shootings
just days apart in Virginia and Colorado
but police say there was no known
credible threat to the festivities rest
assured there will be officers at UC and
officers that you will not see we are
here in the air we are here in the
crowds we're here along the river we're
here to keep you safe
now we just heard a little girl scream
mommy look it's SpongeBob the minions
and Papa Smurf also expected to be
popular and we can't forget the
performances at appearances by Paula
Abdul Kirk Franklin and the queen of
this season Mariah Carey Michelle
Elise thank you